on est là pour défendre les intérêts des
canadiens on sera toujours là pour
défendre la gestion de l'offre et nos
producteurs de lait nous allons toujours
défendre notre industrie de bois
d'oeuvre à illies travailleurs à à
travers le pays
sauvé des conversations avec les
américains certains va toujours avoir à
quelques différends mais comme on a su
très bien le démontrer
on va toujours être là pour défendre les
canadiens
richard ouellette et professeur de droit
international économique à l'université
laval bonsoir chers ouellette
bonsoir temps dans le train pour joe
biden c'est du pareil au même n'est ce
pas en fait les américains sont toujours
pas idem sont aussi protectionnistes que
soudan notre homme
la différence c'est que les choses se
font avec un minimum de cordialité
la plainte qui a été déposée aujourd'hui
la procédure qui a été prise avait été
transmise aux autorités canadiennes la
semaine dernière à l'occasion de la
rencontre de la commission du libre
échange
mais la plainte est la même sous
l'administration drop mais se faire
menacer avec des dix mots vilain sur
twitter d'une tarifs douaniers punitifs
ou de se faire menacer de façon cordiale
par des tarifs punitif sas à coacher
dans tous les cas ça coûte cher dans
tous les cas et dans tous les cas le
canada devra défendre sa politique
d'administration des contingents
tarifaires dans le secteur laitier ya
pas deux alors expliquez nous c'est quoi
les américains qui conteste les
contingents tarifaires par le
gouvernement canadien ce qu'on appelle
aussi les permis d'importation qui
désavantagent 10 des américains les
fermiers américains qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est ça alors les produits
laitiers comme vous l'expliqué bien sont
sous gestion de l'offre au canada et
quand on veut importés au canada des
produits sous gestion de l'offre et un
peu deux façons de faire
il faut faire à faire d'abord avec
quelqu'un qui a un permis d'importation
ce qui permet au produit d'entrée avec
des droits de douane très bas voire
nulles dans beaucoup de cas ou alors on
est au delà des contingents tarifaires
on est au delà des cantiques le canada
veut laisser entrer et là ce moment l'on
paie les fameux tarif douanier hauteur
de 300 % et donald trump dénoncé donc
l'idée pour des producteurs de
l'américain c'est de faire affaire avec
ceux qui ont les permis d'importation et
le canada gère les permis d'importation
et les attributs pour beaucoup de
catégories produits laitiers les
attribue à des transformateurs plutôt
qu'à des distributeurs par la différence
c'est quoi c'est que quand vous êtes un
producteur laitier que vous faites
affaire avec un transformateur votre
marge de profit plus basse et si vous
faites affaire avec quelqu'un qui prend
votre produit il met directement sur les
tablettes à destination du consommateur
final
l'autre élément aussi donc c'est donc
demain une marge de manoeuvre nash de
profits pardon plus basse
pas d'accès direct au moins d'accès
direct aux consommateurs donc les
etats-unis se plaignent du fait que pour
eux les transactions sont beaucoup moins
intéressante
le canada de son côté dit la c ie me
permet de faire ce que je fais et donc
il n'ya pas de ya pas lieu de m'empêcher
d'administrer les contingents tarifaires
que je le fais maintenant
qui a raison et ce qu'on sait les
américains évoquent quatre petits
articles qui sont dans la nex 3 à 2 de
la seo mais qui n'ont jamais été testées
ce sera intéressant de voir je suis
porté à penser pour avoir analysé la
plainte américaine cet après midi je
suis porté à penser que le canada a de
bonnes chances de l'emporter
ok c'est le premier recours là où à peu
près un des premiers recours au
mécanisme des différents depuis qu'on a
signés nouvelle à l'ena oui alors c'est
depuis la mise en place exactement de la
séoune c'est la première fois qu'on va
établir un groupe spécial donc un groupe
darby les états unis activa les
règlements des différends depuis la
somme ils ont activé d'autres modes de
règlement des différends avec le mexique
là avec le canada c'est une première et
on va voir si cette mécanique loi de
règlement des différends fonctionne bien
est ce que beaucoup d'argent en jeu
les montants sont très difficiles à
évaluer parce que les états unis
prétendent que leur marge de profit est
plus basse et que l'accès aux
consommateurs permettrait de faire plus
de sous du côté canadien ont dit que ça
fait pas de différence
donc ce sera pas nécessairement une
guerre de chiffres en termes de produits
ça va être une guerre de principe et les
la marge de manoeuvre gouvernementale
quand on décide qu'on permet à certains
individus plutôt qu'à d'autres le faire
l'importation des produits laitiers
quelles sont les prochaines étapes ça va
s'échelonner sur sur un certain nombre
de mois
oui là on va tester ce mécanisme qui se
veut rapide normalement ça se gère en
150 jours alors dans le prochain mois on
va nommer le président du groupe spécial
on va nommer les autres membres donc
chaque pays va nommer deux nationaux de
l'autre pays
tout ça va se faire en un mois et par la
suite à 150 jours on est supposé avoir
une décision donc sous la menace et de
l'est leur est pas tellement respecté et
là il s'agira de voir
dans les rares cas où on l'utilisé dans
l'es9 ne pas respecter mais il s'agirait
de voir si ça marche
et tout ça richard wiley on va terminer
là dessus au moment où les états unis
décident d'augmenter les droits
antidumping sur le bois d'oeuvre de 9
18% est ce que c'est surprenant
non faut pas s'en étonner sur ce qu'un
autre mécanisme qui appartient pour
l'instant aux autorités administratives
américaines des américains revoit
périodiquement le prix du bois qu'elle
colle exportent vers les états unis
il compare ce qu'il es t m la juste
valeur marchande est le prix que nous
pratiquons quand nous vendons du bois
aux états unis et la marge entre les
deux c'est la marge de dumping ou la
marque de droits compensateurs pour
laquelle ils nous punissent et l'on veut
la d'oubli c'est pas étonnant parce que
c'était des débats et les états unis
il s'agira de voir jusqu'où jusqu'où le
débord ok ben on aura le plaisir de
reparler du bois d'oeuvre je pense
encore un certain temps et des produits
laitiers aussi vous étiez très clair
chat roulette merci ça va faire grand
plaisir
bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit